Ronaldo forgotten Messi guaranteed goat
do we agree all right I don't know yeah
yeah yeah listen listen who is Ronaldo
I'm talking about football soccer no no
we're talking about it's called football
out I'm the greatest football jersey now
it's football we're Moroccan people
refer to the game flip as Focus okay as
the greatest football journalist in
history I just have to say that now that
Messi
has won a World Cup
I don't even think Ronaldo's in the same
league I don't even I mean like I don't
think he's top two I think it's Messy
mbappe Ronaldo honestly I I don't even
think mbappe is there whoa and Bobby had
a good Hey listen come on come on
23 years old 24 years old ah was it a
hat trick yes yes
I guess you count message did I say he
had a hat trick you said he scored he
said he's a goal but I didn't say he had
a hat all right if we don't count
penalties as goals Messi didn't even
score bro if we don't count penalties
his goals Ronaldo's not even at the
conversation thank you so much boys
always what we really should call them
um I'm telling you I was watching a lot
of highlights on YouTube Mark yeah what
do you think about soccer in general bro
first of all it's the world's game let
me tell you something actually let me
make an actual point let me not be
sarcastic for one moment and make an
actual point
the greatest athlete of all time if not
a sprinter if we're talking about actual
sport athlete if not a sprinter
competitive competitive sport has to be
a football player come on let me explain
why I might know where you're going with
this go ahead are we talking Moroccan
football we talk about Moroccan football
my point is my point is
you cannot be the considered the
greatest athlete of in all of humanity
if you do not play the sport that all of
humanity plays yeah just then most
people play it exactly so Michael Phelps
my argument for why he's not the
greatest athlete he's just the greatest
Paul guy that had a pool he's not the
greatest athlete make him do anything
else he's a goofy yeah he is yeah
there's there's greatest swimmer of all
time what does that mean means you're
good at swimming that's it like you know
how many people I've never been born
near water don't know how to swim trying
my hardest not to look left yeah yeah
who doesn't know how to swim culturally
most cultures don't know how to swim oh
that's true Mark is that true most
cultures do not know how to swim it's
just not part of the culture they're not
taking anything less yet no most
cultures I think it's a luxury most
cultures do not know how to swim you
think a Finnish knows how to swim bro
yeah no I do think they know how to swim
Hawk he's in the water is zero degrees
bro he's scared he's in a mountain bro
yeah he Scandinavia he loves the water
he's gonna get one no matter what ice
bath yeah
they're not going over eight feet in ice
they're not they're not trying to do
that do they do their little buckets but
they're not willing to go to the deep
end little ALS challenge yeah
when I ice bucket I go deep end or what
I do deep ice bath challenge for real
because it's a problem you freeze in
there you die yeah yeah that's next
level Stakes you can't just call your
wife to have her pull you out of your
bathtub like whim off yeah and all those
[ __ ] except for you huberman love you
okay I guess my point is the greatest
competitive athlete of all time has to
be a football player I'm rocking
football just by sheer numbers just by
sheer numbers what about baseball
players bro they win they win the World
Series that's the whole world that's
pretty good it is great marketing but we
all know it's not the whole world yeah
it is the whole world anyone that wants
to play baseball you're welcome but they
don't bro that's what I'm saying Usain
Bolt is the greatest Sportsman of all
time because every person on this planet
has Run 100 meters straight except the
governor of Texas yeah but most people
have now he might be the fastest but did
they do that do they do that the
Paralympics what do you mean you could
just get a wheelchair put some rockets
on it see what happens yo they should do
that yo BattleBots meet Special Olympics
bro charge them up Elon is wasting his
time thank you put some Rockets Behind
These paralysis and see what happens
let's see what parallel parapol
okay so if Messi's the goat that means
he's the greatest competitive athlete of
all time now you're going to put him
over your Boy Floyd
right now
hey bro can I tell y'all something
what's going on everybody fought
[Laughter]
even Abbott slapped somebody up you
don't think Abbott Governor Abbott you
don't think we'll slap the [ __ ] out of
somebody
100 talking all that [ __ ]
on your knees I think 100 more people
have probably fought than played
football more people probably had a slap
box than played football yes 100 no I
never thought I never fought anyone bro
about your brother I might be the
greatest fighter of all time I just
never fought stop it
yeah there you go so that's funny I
might be the sisters would would [ __ ]
pull in your foreskin remember
it's breakfast time
do you remember they were they hook you
like
you like drag you out to breakfast toss
me like we're in Seattle 100 you don't
remember that that never happened that's
why you got a hanging foreskin bro how
do you know it's hanging that's the word
on the street I'm not a sleeping bag yo
that's what
that's what street is you got the
sleeper that is true sometimes yeah I
toss them on my shoulder do you yeah
yeah have you ever tried to like tuck
your toes in it I have actually I have
it looks like a wizard's hat man does it
yeah 100 that wins you just cocoon that
whole [ __ ] over here
defense mechanism I mean like an
armadillo
that's my Chrysalis dude that is a good
ass Point yeah dude if you make a uh I'm
not gonna make a joke so look where's
your foreskin do you know uh yeah when
you already did it yeah your parents
mutilated you and you just donated by my
parents well yeah my parents didn't do
it my mom or dad didn't do it They
begged them to do it though they did the
doctor was like ah we don't want to in
your parents said did we need to you
know what's funny is my parents uh
because you can choose and back in the
day it like baggy jeans or [ __ ] was like
in back in the day literally ask for the
jingle so I got I have a bag of I have a
lot more foreskin than most oh really
yeah this is 100 I don't need 10 months
is that true yeah oh so you have a
little tip I don't know what I was
talking about he got a black tip no no
no I don't I don't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about I know I heard that
you got your [ __ ] cut really tight your
dick look like a rash guard or something
I heard you can't even jerk your dick
you need not enough skin yeah you don't
need to get fully heart attack I donated
all of it yeah
that's his dick listen we just try to
talk about Moroccan football yeah y'all
want to talk about dicks all the goddamn
time all right let's go back best
athlete of all time yeah why Ronaldo
will be forgotten brother's the best
athlete Mayweather is the greatest
athlete of all time okay there's no
questions after Mayweather if we're
going to talk about white sports like
football there we go I was talking about
all sports but Sports where they try to
exclude black people from playing like
Latinos are not white Latinos are not
white that's a Latino I knew I knew
that's awesome he says so he's not
dating a white woman but oh my God
Latinos are not white wow he's not even
dating a Latina yeah I know she's from
she's from Europe yeah she's a Bonafide
Caucasian she's Spanish I was hoping you
would bring that up yeah yeah yeah well
she couldn't honestly technically she
could have African Roots she could
because the Moroccans God bless theirs
okay can we get back on yeah I really
there are people that tuned in for a
series his conversation about as they
should Moroccan football yeah yeah
because I'm the greatest football
journalist of all time